alrighty then it is time for drew's news
the good news sprinkles on your news
cake with that satisfying good news
crunch
the sprinkles crunch they do yeah i have
some experience with them and they do
right they get your teeth you know what
i'm talking about i think they're just
so pretty i never eat them well with me
at the desk is uh the best co-pilot in
the world rossi ross matthews
[Applause]
please don't get me sprinkles please
look at my body i'm trying to keep it
together don't get me anything with
sprinkles on it no
pendulum over here
well we are starting with style news now
remember we are losing our minds over
netflix's new deal with nancy meyers to
make a new movie
okay so metro reports that the latest
style icon is diane keaton in every
nancy myers movie ever yes and
understood trend is officially called
the coastal grandmother look um all
right well the style is cozy chic and
very breathable
for uh some inspo check out diane and
something's got to give any day all day
i'll watch that movie oh yeah okay i see
coastal there yeah well i mean there's
an ocean so if you don't see coastal
something's wrong with you let's see
meryl streep and it's complicated oh
yeah uh-huh giving her santa barbara
bath yes
we're talking linens neutrals anything
with that good flow for sitting back and
draining that bottle of wine um and i
also love a like a cream
cable knit turtleneck with a linen pant
and a bottle of pinot grigio i am living
my coastal grandmother fantasy just
about every single day we're all picking
up what nancy myers is putting down
thank you so much uh well next up we've
got an insane story from your hometown
of los angeles joe oh yeah listen to
this npr reports a woman was standing at
one of those lottery ticket vending
machines oh this is crazy she was
deciding which scratcher ticket she was
going to buy when a stranger rudely
bumped into her hitting her arm made her
purchase a 30 ticket which she never
would have picked if it were up to her
and she was so irritated she went back
to her car she scratched it off and she
won 10 million dollars can you believe
this story
i didn't think things like this were
possible have you ever won anything on
like a lottery ticket or my life your
life yeah you won the lottery didn't you
yeah i feel like i did yeah oh that's
cute
that's cute
well okay
with all its ups and downs yeah
that's a way more poignant answer than
mine one time i accidentally hit the bet
max on a penny slot in palm springs it
was five dollar spin
and i won a hundred dollars i did
on pennies no
yes it doesn't i mean
still spitting out pennies as we speak
because well hundred dollars in pennies
like that's how the pilgrims did slot
machines now they just give you a little
uh piece of paper that's at a hundred
dollars yes no yeah you don't get coins
anymore no coins no no when does last
time you went to a casino 1970 what
come on i'm always on the blackjack
table oh
and i um
i like to split fives and do everything
wrong and make the whole table mad at me
and the dealer's furious and the people
who are riding are just mad at me but
i i tend to do okay so it pays off that
risky behavior pays off for you
[Music]
you